hello everyone and today we're gonna be
talking about our studio server in our
studio server Pro just to help give
everybody a sense of what the value
proposition is for our use of a broth so
let's start with just our studio server
and what it does the open source server
is a way for you to take the IDE that
you know and love for your desktop and
be able to bring it to your web browser
basically being able to move the
computation and and the RAM to a
centralized location so organizations
usually look at running our studio
server when when they want to provide
their analysts with access to greater
compute than they otherwise would have
been able to get on other laptops or
more RAM so some organizations as we've
talked to can you know have you know 16
32 64 cores in some cases even a hundred
cores and and in some cases up to a
terabyte of RAM so obviously that's a
lot more than what you can get on a
single laptop and the other reason that
people like to run the server is for
them to centralize computation to for
them to centralize access to data so if
they have large data data clusters and
whatnot this allows them to do the
analysis near the near the data as
opposed to bring it back down to to the
laptop and it finally it's really
convenient because now you can access it
from any class device that has a web
browser so all the other the other
benefit that we that people leverage the
server for is to be able to constrain
which version of our and which version
of that our libraries their users can
use those are all the benefits of the
open source art studio server on the
left hand side there you see different
user browsers that are connecting again
this could be ie Firefox Chrome and
you're talking the server showing you
the centralization of access to the
r-process
our environment
the pro edition is geared really towards
making it easier for the server to be
integrated within an enterprise
environment so there are a lot of
features and capabilities that are
useful for IT organizations to be able
to have comfort and adopting are so
there are better tools for management of
sessions and and resources as well as
metrics monitoring and and features
around high availability so we'll start
with the the administrative dashboard
and the first top left there you'll see
that we give you a view into the running
server so you can see the CPU usage the
memory usage the load average and
historical view of the sessions versus
the memory versus CPU utilization the
load average and the second region there
we sort of show you the list of users
that have been using the system at all
you know over the last thirty days you
get to see their ID but remember usage
the amount of CPU and if you wanted to
you can dig in on any of those users and
and get a better feel for what they've
what they've done and potentially what
errors they've seen finally you get a
chance to see sort of the running
sessions right now so if who's active we
have the server right this minute you
can do things like suspend that the
session if you have my privileges you
can terminate this at that session if
you have the right privileges or you can
conceivably take over that session if
they had an issue they had a problem
that they needed help with next we have
a whole bunch of statistics that we're
sort of capturing to help help the IT
person or whoever's managing the server
to get a feel for what's going on the
server so if there are slowdowns and
occurring all of the metrics that we
show you here are ones that you could
configure to send it to your own system
so that you could use the existing tools
and use existing learning infrastructure
that you have so people are sort of tied
these graphite or HP openview or
whatever your favorite tool is and then
finally on the on the right hand side
there there's a quick way of searching
the logs seeing what errors are showing
up being able to slice and dice them in
different ways so that an IT person or
the person managing the cluster it can
can get a better feel for the problems
that are being seen so again similar to
the previous model your users on one
side the server on the other
the biggest difference again is the fact
that you now have an admin dashboard and
then we've introduces a lot of
capabilities around integrating with Pam
and Pam sessions so you can do
integrations with LDAP and Active
Directory you all of the traffic is as
SSL encrypted you can also even specify
IP restrictions so he wanted to make
sure that people could only access this
when they're behind a VPN or a firewall
you can sort of manage that here we're
put together a fictitious example of two
different teams that we've constructed
one is the compliance team that for the
purpose of this exercise needs to be on
an earlier version of our that's been
validated for example right so and they
may have you may not want to give them
all the cores on the box and you wanna
restrict how much RAM they use in
contrast there's another group that we
have that's called the power user group
and and this particularly again is a
fictitious group that will we'll be able
to run the latest version of our and and
have no restrictions on
so really the cores that are available
or the priority that they have and so
you can see that with the notion of
groups you can really try and and the IT
administrator if you really constrain
who has access to what resources on the
server then allows them to better manage
it and and make sure that the experience
is very good for everyone who's using
that server finally we come to one of
the key features for our server Pro
which is around providing a highly
available environment so as our becomes
more important in the enterprise you
want to be able you want to be able to
have a cluster that's always up and
always available and so as part of Pro
we ship with five different ways in
which you can configure low balancing
and so we'll start with a the active
session low balancing scheme again
there's this particular example has
three servers you can have a cluster of
two or five or however many you need
each of these servers has a shared file
system and in the active session load
balancing scheme the the algorithm
attempts to keep the number of sessions
even across all the other different
servers and so a has three users on it
be s 2 and C has 3 and so when user 9
shows up you would expect it to end up
on sir would be the CP utilization load
balancing scheme is similar but now
targeting extending traffic to the C
machine that has the least usage and so
in this particular case this particular
machines server B has 10% so you'd
expect that the next years you're coming
would get routed to it your user hash
load-balancing you can use this
algorithm to really divvy up the world
of users that are coming and have it be
more predictable about which server it's
gonna put them on and so you know if you
have you know John Mary and Sam they
they may end up always on you know a B
and C respectively
so it's a little more predictable in the
sense that you will always the cluster
size remains the same you're more likely
you are very likely to end exactly the
same note every time and then the
customer balancing scheme is one that
gives you the ability to create your own
algorithm for selecting where the
session should get started first and so
whenever a new session is about to start
and if you have custom you need a custom
script will the server will call out and
you will have the option of specifying
given the data you're given which which
server to be started on in this
particular case we have it just starting
on server B because maybe server breed
is is I was always available for a
certain for a certain group of people
right so let's say it's either a much
faster observer or a much much faster
machine or maybe it's a slower machine
that you don't want it you only want to
send a certain group of people
and finally all those low balancing
algorithms can also be put to use behind
a third party load balancer and so you
could be using an that scalar and net in
genetics and Apache little bouncer and
and have it routed to them appropriate
all right so that runs you through the
basic set of features available on our
sugar syrup row if you'd like to
actually see a list of the the
comparison table you can visit it at the
following URL and we normally encourage
people to start with the open source
edition get your usage there get some
familiarity with the product and then as
you require some of the more advanced
features you can download the eval copy
there's a 45 day eval copy that's
available a long way that the
administration guide which which walks
you through how to configure all these
features thank you